so good morning
and let me be the first to wish you a
happy shark week if you haven't been
paying attention discovery channel is
all sharks all the time this week uh
hopefully this will be at least as
interesting to you
i'm norman beer directing the open
learning initiative at carnegie mellon
i've had at least a few people ask so
far
what's carnegie mellon doing at a
conference devoted to learning with
moocs because
in many ways we've been staying out of
the mooc game
sometimes very loudly and so uh
in some ways i think this will be an
answer that we're not sitting completely
outside of the mooc space but instead
we're doing a lot of work that we
believe
can very effectively complement much of
the access and the research that's
happening through moocs how many of you
know what the open learning initiative
is
well fantastic then my next few slides
can go pretty quickly
this one so the open learning initiative
is an ongoing research project at
carnegie mellon our focus has been the
integration of learning science with
technology to build effective online
learning environments that can
simultaneously uh
enact instruction for students and
improve our understanding of human
learning so
the way that we approach this has been
through a very careful design process on
the front end starting off with the uh
look at student-centered measurable
learning outcomes and thinking carefully
with a team about how we can build
learning activities that will support
students in achieving those ends
we've been doing this work since 2002
and our original charge had been to
focus on enacting learning for
independent students independent
learners what we discovered pretty
quickly was that this kind of careful
approach to design
can also create materials that can be
exceptionally valuable in the hands of
experienced faculty and so our charge
changed fairly quickly we now look to
support better learning and also better
instruction both through the creation of
learning materials but also through the
creation of tools to support that
instruction we share our courses openly
and freely and this sharing serves a
number of purposes one of them from our
original charge has been to support an
access agenda but we also think that
this sharing feeds directly into this
larger mission that we have of improving
our understanding of how people learn
the larger a population we have
participating in our courses the more
we're able to learn from them
when we talk about designing an oli
course
folks often think that we're just
talking about a technology but instead
we're talking about an entire approach
to developing learning experiences what
we want to incorporate straight off from
the beginning is science both the
science of learning in terms of how this
influences how we craft our learning
experiences but also on the back end as
we engage in very regular and thoughtful
considerations of how effective these
designs have been we recognize that we
don't know everything about how to build
effective learning experiences
and so
much of the work that we do represent a
hypothesis on how we can help students
achieve specific learning outcomes and
if we're going to be honest we need to
take that step back and consider
how well did we do and
quite frequently we'll need to step back
and say that hypothesis wasn't quite
right
the technology is obviously important
but equally important is a team-based
approach and we think this is one of the
things that really distinguishes our
work from some of the other efforts to
move learning online that we're not
looking to take a faculty members course
online we instead take that faculty
member and work with other content
experts and other experts in learning
science and educational technology in
user experience
bring them together and really be
thoughtful about how we apply those
different expertises to craft a learning
experience that focuses on these
outcomes
in addition to the team-based approach
we are a little bit fanatical about data
capture and i know that
it's popular to talk about the large
gobs of data that you're gathering at
this point and so i'm happy to give you
the big numbers of the data that we
capture
but i think the important points about
data capture within an oli course is
that we've been able to fairly carefully
instrument this data and wrap it in some
semantic context so it's not just that
i've got some large amount of click
stream information but i can start to
say some things about those clicks and
what they represent with regard to the
kinds of outcomes we're trying to
achieve
this data is used in a lot of different
ways and probably most crucially it's to
give feedback to the learner but equally
important we give feedback to
the instructor population we use the
information to guide iterative course
improvement and finally we're using this
information to try to advance our
understanding of how people learn
some of the work that i'm going to be
talking about today will end up crossing
the line between these most particularly
between improved course design and
improved science of learning
so
when we think about the outputs of this
one of the ones that's best known is the
oli learning dashboard sitting
underneath many of our courses is a
cognitive model that's going to be
making estimates
based on student performance against our
activities on how well they have
achieved these learning outcomes gives
faculty members a chance to quickly
identify where their class seems to be
doing well where they need additional
support then allow them to drill in and
identify more carefully what are the
misconceptions that seem to be really
causing students problems and allow them
to spend their instructional time
drilling in on those areas
this also gives us some pretty
interesting behind-the-scenes data in
estimating how well students are
learning across these different skills
and these different learning objectives
though
we've been fairly successful and if
you've heard about oli most likely i
don't need to dive into some of the past
research studies uh maybe more
importantly you're not in this room to
hear about the past work so what is this
project with regard to the moocs where
did it come from it actually comes out
of an earlier project called the
community college open learning
initiative
our goal with ccoli was to take some of
the work that we've been doing and
really take a much deeper dive into the
community college space this was
partnering with faculty and experts in
community colleges to identify four
gatekeeper courses two of which we'd
already done some work on two of which
were new we wanted to build these out to
address the needs of the community
college population and see if we could
really improve effectiveness in these
courses where we know that students
struggle
one of these courses is psychology
and in participating in
the development of the course we looked
not just for community college faculty
but also for other interested uh domain
experts and one of those came to us from
georgia tech
at about the time that our course was
wrapping up finally i get to the meat of
this story
uh georgia tech decided that they were
going to be delivering a mooc on
psychology so this is about the time uh
late 2012 early 2013
that the gates foundation had put out a
fairly large call
for
offering 100 to 200 level moocs and
drilling in on the evaluation side of
this how effective are they in in terms
of the population that the foundation
was trying to reach
in talking with georgia tech we felt
like they had some ideas for how they
wanted to deliver this mooc they also
recognized that they just participated
in building this fabulous resource the
oli psychology course and so together we
decided that they were going to offer
the mooc but offer it using this oli
course
this ended up leaving a fairly clean set
of
responsibilities both for each party but
also for each system and so from the
student perspective they were signing on
to the mooc platform within the mooc
platform they were getting video
lectures they were participating in
discussion forums
they were also using uh lti to get sent
over to work through oli modules in our
original vision the faculty member was
going to be then reviewing the learning
dashboard and using this to guide the
video lectures that he'd be recording
turned out that was a little overly
ambitious and was expecting a little too
much turnaround time um so they ended up
using the dashboard to guide instruction
and support inside of the discussion
forums
what this got us is some very rich data
sets so
on the side of the mooc we have the
traditional click stream information
particularly representing these video
interactions
high stakes assessments and a separate
data set around discussion within the
oli side we have our learning
interaction data set and this has
actually now been loaded into data shop
and is available for folks to take a
look at and a separate data set that we
call our evaluation report we've got
lots and lots of information and this
has given us the chance to just start
scratching the surface on understanding
how can the use of these kinds of
carefully designed
learning environments be used in the
mooc context
it also gave us some really interesting
possibilities for comparison because in
addition to the use in the mooc context
we have an r1 institution that was using
this exact same mooc in teaching their
students so we have a classroom-based
mooc and finally around the community
college open learning initiative we've
got a large population of students
that have used oli in different
face-to-face contexts but with similar
demographics
also interesting we have some pre and
post-test data that is common across the
mooc and the ccoli we had permission
from the college board to use the uh ap
psychology test or a selection from it
as our pre-post measures
so when i was uh walking in here one of
my colleagues was looking at my slide
deck and saying norman you really need
to kill your darlings here this is way
too long and i'm looking at the clock
and cognizant that he was right
i'm going to be moving through some of
these pieces fairly quickly so that we
can get to the discussion point if i
start moving too quickly
throw something at me or make a note so
that we can come back to it
so this is a fairly important point what
we've been trying to dig into are
evidence of effectiveness and evidence
of learning and uh despite some rumors
to the contrary we believe there are
some ways
to measure these things that we can say
some meaningful things about them within
the context of these data sets these are
some of the ways that we've considered
both effectiveness and learning the
third party assessment instrument in
this case is the ap pre and post test
but we also feel that we've got some
fairly reliable high stakes activities
both in the mooc and inside of oli
completion was interesting although
mostly only useful for our ccoli set um
and finally these oli learning estimates
we feel tell us some interesting things
about the interaction between activities
in the oli context the activities on the
mooc context
things that i want to talk about what
can i say about inside the mooc what can
i say in those comparisons
i'll probably be skipping these new
approaches for iterative improvement
other areas of research i've got someone
that can talk a bit about when we get
into the facilitation side of things
challenges and future steps
i'd also like to give credit to the
cadre of grad students that were really
essential in
prepping this data set for me i cannot
claim full credit for this and jihad
chem in particular has been
really important so give credit where
it's due
this is what a typical
week in the mooc
looked like students were given a series
of videos and then sent over to work
through a set of oli modules they could
work through this at their own pace and
they would eventually return by the end
of the week to take a quiz inside of the
mooc
some of the early research questions we
wanted to understand what was the impact
of oli on dropout rates
what was this comparison on pre-post
and is there any difference in terms of
using oli in overall performance
what we discovered is that yes in fact
engaging with the oli activities seems
to correlate with a lesser uh dropout
rate but this makes sense when you think
about the larger mooc context
we also saw that engaging with the
activities had a real and significant
effect on the post-test score in this
case this was an exam that was
administered inside of the coursera
system
there's a lot of information that we can
dive into to talk about differences in
demographics and i'm going to come back
to this in this case we were trying to
consider performance on the coursera
quizzes both with and without use of the
oli activities
summarize that fairly quickly uh what we
discovered wasn't completely shocking
that the kinds of occupations and people
that you would expect tended to do a
little better we didn't see age having
much of an impact but we were a little
surprised at the gender distinction
what was most interesting though is
really considering how do we drive
success or what kinds of activities and
work should we be recommending students
to engage in
and we're comparing some very basic
measures of use of oli against success
on relevant quizzes
what we saw here is a pretty close
relationship between success and
engaging with the learning activities um
there's obviously some relationship as
well with uh simply taking a look at the
pages and so what we'll be recommending
to students based on this is yeah it's
good to go in and read this stuff but if
you really want to get some value go in
and carefully engage in the learning
activities that have been constructed
looking at the comparative information
first
the top is the mooc the bottom is ccoli
we're looking at age and clearly we have
a much younger population engaged in the
community college work
similarly we're looking at degrees now
phds masters bachelors associates and
high school
so it's my first question here is what
are all of you people doing taking an
introduction to psychology mooc because
that's who was predominantly showing up
for this intro to psych piece and i
think it had a pretty tremendous impact
on the results
drilling in on these learning estimate
questions interestingly we end up seeing
fairly similar patterns between our mooc
students and our community college
students
and this really starts to come out when
we look into how many activities they
participated in and so we end up
breaking that out by
25 percent jumps
finally when we look at the early use of
activities between ccli and our mooc
students we're seeing that
especially in the early phase even doing
a little bit on the activity side seems
to lead to improved learning gain
amongst the community college students
but when we move into this space of
engaging actively against all of the
activities this balance is out again we
don't see huge distinctions between our
mooc and our community college student
performance
pre-post-tests however we saw a much
different
set of information and so clearly the
mooc students were coming in at a higher
level and they were achieving higher
learning gains this is using the ap exam
we drilled in a little deeper because i
think the place that this is most
interesting is within the high school
population students that have finished
high school and do not have a degree
even there we've ended up seeing some
distinctions that were frankly a little
surprising and
just sort of scratching the surface on
this so i don't have a great explanation
on it
within
uh
ccoli and within the mooc we also want
to look at the impact of engaging with
learning activities on post-test results
and pre-test results what you see here
is not surprising on the ccoli side
engage with the activities and you're
going to do better on the
post-test
you see a much more interesting pattern
on the mooc side and again one that i
don't have a fantastic explanation for
except to sort of look at the population
that i have engaged
beyond these early explorations these
data sets have also allowed us to look
at some other areas of research
one of them has been work in data
analysis between different
data sets i'm actually going to let
carolyn address that in just a minute
we've also been able to use this mooc
data to drill in more deeply on
iterative improvement questions the
pittsburgh science of learning center
team has been looking at our mooc data
to identify places where we're not
getting very good learning curves and
try to address this by
identifying outcomes that we can both
build richer learning activities but
also move the learning outcome a little
more towards something higher on bloom's
taxonomy so moving from some simple
questions to things that are a bit more
scenario based
some of the challenges in doing this
work uh matching between students and
dealing with dropout rates and um you
know this is the bane of any mooc
research so i'm not telling you anything
new here
data sharing agreements have been a real
challenge and in part this is because of
this the sheer number of irb protocols
with which we need to engage
logistics of making all of this work
just setting up appropriate systems
making the oli system available
so all of these things have made the
research pretty challenging and if i
were to go back and do it again and
hopefully i will be some of these i'm
going to try to get in front of
particularly on the data sharing side i
think that this has been one of the
places where
we ended up putting in a lot of effort
and finding out on the back end that
some components we couldn't be sharing
future directions lots more information
to analyze we've just had this same mooc
run a second time and
what we're really hoping to do is repeat
these kinds of experiments with other
courses
obviously the psychology has been
interesting and fairly successful but
we've got a lot of other courses that we
think could be used to support
moocs in interesting ways
so when we talk about
the facilitated discussion piece
obviously happy to take any questions
and go back and look at some of the
box plots that i flew through
but i think probably more interesting
for some of our time here is to consider
not just within oli but more broadly how
can we move towards more common measures
of learning and effectiveness so that we
don't always feel like we've got to come
up here and make it up or defend the
decisions that we've made
how can we more carefully integrate
these kinds of designed activities into
the mooc experience
and finally
more broadly how do we better facilitate
these kinds of research and evaluation
questions whether this is integrating it
into the design of a course whether it's
accounting for irb challenges before the
work gets started and how do we
facilitate this data sharing
you know with a nod to appropriate
concerns for learner and educator
privacy
so i've gone five minutes over my
allocated 15 and i've thrown an awful
lot of information at you but uh before
i open it up for questions i actually
wanted to introduce carolyn rose
um so i was very excited to bring these
data sets together and uh you know
immediately began running around campus
saying who wants to do some research and
carolyn was the first one to stand up so
carolyn can you talk a little bit about
uh some of the work that you've been
able to do with the data sets sure um so
i'll just mention three um briefly areas
of work that my group has been doing and
then let people ask follow-up questions
if they're interested one has been
a lot of analyses of discussion data
i'm a language technologies professor
and
so we've been looking at those
discussions to see what kinds of things
can we actually detect about students
that might help us to develop
interventions
to support especially students who seem
like they're at risk of dropping out so
we've looked at things like motivation
cognitive engagement social
connectedness attitudes towards the
course confusion um so that's one line
of research
another is that we have been developing
interventions themselves and making them
easy to deploy in moocs in an edx
context or a coursera context you know
we've been working with this lti
protocol it was very easy to do that
wrapper so we think we could also
integrate our interventions in other
platforms as well and that includes
support for small group collaborative
learning activities as well as
for interventions to help people get
connected in the threaded discussions
looking for ways of matching help
seekers and help providers but a third
area which really kind of
dovetails on the keynote talk from this
morning is that i've really been pushing
and also in my new role as
president-elect of the international
society of the learning sciences to get
more crosstalk between communities
getting the technology people and the
learning scientists really to work in
close partnership and as part of that
i'm organizing a workshop that norm
mentions where we're using the
psychology mooc data as a shared data
set to get teams from various different
universities to
apply their modeling techniques it's at
a machine learning
conference
to see what they can understand about
the data and in order to get a
discussion going between people who are
strong on modeling but might not know
what questions they should be asking
with their models or how to interpret
their models and in the context of that
workshop at this conference where we
expect that a lot of the contribution
will be from computer scientists that
we'll have keynote talks from learning
scientists who will talk about their
perspective on the data what they see
and what questions they would ask and we
hope then that that will really start to
get some of these really deep
partnerships going that we need in this
community in order to really push things
forward so i'll leave it at that
thanks
um
so
even within this individual data set and
even within this individual experience
there's still plenty more to dig into
but i i'd really like to throw out here
a call to action because i think
one of the most important parts of the
original oli mission
was and continues to be this notion of
making these materials openly available
and seeing them used in a variety of
contexts
a barrier to this that we've never been
able to leap
at least not perfectly has been
getting around the not invented here
syndrome the notion that we've got these
carefully designed full course
experiences that could then be
integrated into other contexts whether
it's mooc or classroom
just opens up so many possibilities and
doors and yet we don't see
the engagement with it that we would
have hoped for and that we expect i
think we were very fortunate with in the
psychology context because we had some
engagement with this institution and
with the participants and they
recognized that yes here's a course that
we've helped to design we know that it
can support work in our mooc it has the
appropriate open licensing to make this
easy
how do i convince the rest of you that
uh we've got all these great resources
and how can we work together to take the
resources that have been built and
instead focus our attention on building
new things that are going to leverage
that
um and this isn't just a question for
the mooc research i think but it is
really one of the long-standing
questions in the open education
community
so that was more of a sermon than a than
a question i apologize it started as a
question um let me turn it over to you
what questions do you have
yes
hi i'm catherine hicks from ucsd
and i had a couple of quick questions
about the data so one is that um
you know you have some interesting
effects especially like the gender thing
are there any interaction effects
between all those things
and if so
are you still puzzling that out we're
still puzzling it out and part of this
is uh i mean the other challenge has
been
how many students we actually get
answering the demographic survey
information and so those places where
things have been rich enough to really
drill in on interaction
the effect of education and occupation
in this has been so overpowering that uh
finding a smaller population
has been challenging
on the ccoli side i think we do a little
bit of a better job of of teasing out um
what some of those interaction effects
are there's a pretty decent write-up of
this um it's been published on the oli
site it's also available on uh the ulit
foundation's website called the ccli
evaluation report thanks yeah and i just
the other quick data question was when
you were talking you were talking about
um
analyzing discussion stuff and i assume
that that's you know very much like the
natural language kind of yeah so um so
you mentioned all of these um were any
of them predictive are you still looking
at that yeah so what which were
exactly what you would expect students
who are confused
are you know that's associated with
higher dropouts but what's kind of
interesting is that actually exposure to
other confused students was much
stronger in its effect than actually
students who express confusion
themselves so students who are around a
lot of students who are expressing
confusion have a 45 higher dropout rate
um uh so
we also see that um social connectedness
is really important it's not surprising
that students who've made more
connections stay longer but what's
interesting is that when the people who
they've connected with start to drop out
they are much more likely almost twice
as likely
to drop out that varies a little bit
between classes we always see the effect
the strength varies a little bit um you
also see students who are more
cognitively engaged have a lower dropout
rate you know so it's a lot of the
things that you would expect but the
important thing is that we can detect
changes within a student's
attitude or
you know
whatever over time and so we can start
to see those places where they look like
they're vulnerable and if there are
limited resources for offering support
we can target the students who are at
risk at the time when they're at risk
and hopefully that will allow us to have
more impact so um i just want to say
very briefly that only a small
proportion of students actually
participate in the discussion so that
only allows us to monitor a small
proportion of the students but what
we're doing now is looking for
connections between how people express
themselves in the discussion forums and
the patterns routines and
practices that we see in the quick
stream data and the hope is then that we
can get more insight into what those
click stream patterns mean from the
discussion data for that small
proportion of students who participate
and then we can project out
that ability to see those things in the
quick stream data to the students who
don't participate in the discussions um
can i just really quickly ask too like
it seems like you know it's such an
interesting problem like how do does it
trouble you you know or do you make this
distinction between like the fact that
these students are all talking to each
other you know together makes it almost
difficult to figure out what is the unit
you know that you're analyzing right and
in the the individual student unit you
know considering that they're part of
actually a conversation you know
somebody could argue that that's not
really the unit really the unit is just
this whole forum or something like that
how do you puzzle that out
i think that those are and those are
questions that we are considering and
we're looking at models that explore
different
units of analysis and
sorry about that um so working we're
definitely considering those questions
they're complicated questions we don't
have a pad answer but we totally
acknowledge that's good thinking
so it looks like neil back there has a
question
yeah um i'm your olympian from most
applied technical student i don't think
i need the mic um my question is
actually do you did this cool stuff to
actually make lti actually work right
through edx and i know dave dave pitcher
there actually had a postdoc yesterday
to talk about actually using the uh
i thought he was doing an lti
probably many people in the room that
have other little objects that like to
integrate into courses just like you
guys actually integrated yourself can
you say a little bit more about actually
how difficult that was uh is there code
available that edx can actually help
other people actually do this we're
right in the middle we just got funded
for project x they do the lti
integration for edx as we have all this
math content that we want to actually
be able to be available and so
um and also can you address the issue
that lci actually allows you to pull
down rosters but also push back up data
and is headaches ready to actually
accept data back up
yeah so uh first quick correction we
actually did this with with the coursera
system um i i've been uh begging some
folks at edx to try the same stunt um in
an edx course and we've got a couple of
possibilities there
on the lti side i think that this is
who knows what lti is if i start diving
in
half of you so
lti is a standard for making learning
objects and learning tools interoperable
and you can think of needing to have two
pieces of implementation on lti as a
tool provider i need to provide
mechanisms so that others can plug into
my tool pass me appropriate information
and get information back
as a tool consumer this would be edx or
coursera in this context they would need
to provide the code that allows them to
reach out and make use of these various
lti tools both edx and coursera have
already done the lifting on the tool
consumer side of things although that
hadn't been true in 2013
we were working with corsair engineers
right up until the day of course launch
to make sure that they could use our lti
integration
i think that as the lti standard has
matured and more and more
folks have integrated this into their
tools
implementation keeps getting easier
because folks keep publishing mechanisms
and toolkits for implementing so i think
at this point adding on the necessary
bits to a reasonably well architected
system to allow you to be a tool uh
provider
is relatively simple i mean it requires
some software development it requires a
little bit of engineering
but it's not the lift that it was even
two years ago
part of the trick though is in making
effective use of lti and and i think a
lot of this really falls back on the
user experience side of things it's very
easy to just throw in an lti link that
suddenly sends students off somewhere
else and this leaves them confused
doesn't make a strong connection with
wherever their original
consumer platform
had been
and so thinking carefully about how this
experience gets integrated into these
larger platforms has been pretty
important and has been one of the things
that impacts student completion on the
lti side
that said this does give you the freedom
to not have to integrate completely
right you can maintain your own wrapper
and maintain your own user interface
metaphor you just want to think a little
carefully about making that boundary
between the two a little more seamless
that answer your question of uh and i'm
happy to dive a little more into the
technical details but um
and i think as we hit lti 2.0 we're
going to see a lot more uh useful
information coming back on the data side
and that that hasn't been the case to
this point
that's really important is that a lot of
people who build these things or who
want to use them they just want to use
them and then
the data are not in a form
uh they're not neither communicated nor
are they a useful form it's um
see if i can
go back on my obnoxiously long power
point here
as i was saying obnoxiously long so this
i mean this really was one of the
challenges that we face even with lti
we've ended up with four distinct data
sets and we've ended up having to do an
awful lot of work in matching students
between these that becomes painful
because of other irb constraints and
because of honest attempts to uh to
protect student privacy many of our data
sets by default will anonymize on their
own student identity and um needing to
get them to back out that anonymization
to say no first you need to
match with some of these other data sets
and then we can anonymize has been a
challenge because many of them were just
never designed to deal with that you
know because who does that why would you
build in mechanisms of your system to
de-anonymize data right this is uh it's
just not what we do with learning data
yeah hi i just had a question about sort
of the feedback loops between the data
and and instruction so in k12 i mean
there are tons and tons of these teacher
dashboards that have been created but
the problem is that the teachers really
don't know how to act upon the data that
because it's very dispersed and i'm
wondering whether that's been maybe
better solved in higher ed but
how do you um how do you think about
whether or not the
you know the sort of in the next
lecture that the mooc provider is is
giving how are they taking into
consideration the data that they've just
received
so i think that this is no different in
higher ed than it is k through 12. uh
one of the findings from the ccoli study
on the one hand was that um one of the
biggest influences on how students used
the materials and succeeded was how
faculty used these materials and um but
we also found that it's remarkably hard
to integrate this stuff into your
practice um tom cortina the computer
science faculty member at cmu been
working with him on uh cs course
and uh
the first pilot that he ran we built out
this learning dashboard after we had
worked with him to build out a course he
went out he got in front of his students
gave them his original talk sent them
off to work through these modules and
then sat down with a member of our team
to review the dashboard results and we
found that one of these outcomes that
students still weren't getting and he
sort of you know got this puzzled look
on his face said you know
the problem is i've already given you my
best stuff like what am i going to go in
and tell these students
this really represents a fundamentally
different model for approaching your
classroom it's it's and it's not
something that can easily be prepared
far in advance
and i think that we're all still
figuring out how to make use of these
tools
however we've seen faculty adjust to
this and do it really effectively and i
think part of the trick is going to be
capturing a larger body of knowledge on
how do we rapidly change instructional
strategies based on the kinds of
feedback that these instruments can
provide
that said i wish i had a perfect answer
for it but
i know it's possible and we're still
figuring out the best way to support
faculty and making those transitions
and and one of the things you really
really have to work out for especially
as you get away from
uh from physics or math professors is
hey graphs are not so easy to determine
you know to understand i mean i've seen
demonstrations for enthusiastic faculty
when the first question was well gee i'd
really like to know uh you know the time
distribution of my students well hey we
just showed you these four graphs and
that was the first one in the top left
and you didn't get the message i mean
and these are people who really want to
learn how you get the attention of
people father down the food chain who
don't go to these meetings and don't go
to these workshops in a way that they
can look at it so quickly that they not
only have actionable data but that they
see immediately that an action is needed
is is a huge problem and it's also
a acknowledged problem in the
psychometrics community how we got all
this stuff how do we display it
and i think part of this is also a
challenge of incentives so i i think uh
really drilling home the notion that
being able to adapt your instructional
strategies in this way leaves you
walking into the classroom and engaging
with your students in a way that really
does draw upon your expertise that
you're not covering the same kinds of
things over and over again but instead
you can build an instructional
experience that's going to be more
satisfying and valuable for you as an
instructor not just for the learner
because something needs to motivate the
engagement with these tools and then the
move away from business as usual
part of its user interface part of its
incentive though
yeah i like to pick up on the uh the
question that you raised on your last
slide you don't need to go back to it
about uh possible metrics of of success
and engagement uh what is going on in
the course and it's really challenging
um especially so one example of a
challenge is is the dropout because if
you use a pre-test and a protest
you might see that there are fewer
people in the post-test than you had in
the pretest and usually those people who
actually answer the post-test are not a
random sample of the people who answer
pre-tests but the ones who are as
successful
to get to the end and complete that test
at the end right so it's probably an
overestimate by far from what i've seen
of what you would actually get because
all of these other people have already
dropped out or got too frustrated and
that is a big challenge for coming up
with metrics that are
uh that are
that are
that are actually measuring what we want
to measure without inducing biases also
when we run experiments
the the only metric that you can really
look at when you run an experiment in a
mooc and you give people two conditions
over time
is dropout because that is the thing
that does not change with the population
that you're measuring if you're
measuring continuously say you want to
measure cognitive load in a mooc over
time well the people who might
experience high cognitive load cognitive
overload in one condition will drop out
faster most probably you don't even know
that for sure but if you try and compare
by week five your populations are very
probably not alike anymore and so the
comparison will be biased so it is very
hard because of dropouts
and i'm wondering if you
have any ideas on that well even beyond
just dropout one of the other challenges
that we saw in ccli is our various
protocols did not allow us to include
pre and posttest as any part of the
grade we couldn't incentivize inside of
the course and so students were taking
the uh pre and post test simply to
win a chance to win an ipad
and and it shows when you read some of
these exams i mean students would just
go in and push submit on and so i i know
that my postdesk data is pretty
horrendous
two areas that have been exciting but
that are very very early stage and you
saw this in some of the slides one is
that we do have some models that are
producing learning estimates and i think
as we gain greater comfort with those
and as we as we build out some of the
models for producing them these are
going to give us some clear measures for
comparison
the second is i think that at least
looking at
population to population and course
version to course version there's a lot
to be said for using the learning curves
that are coming out of pslc's data shop
again it gives me some kind of standard
measure for comparison at least looking
at those students that have engaged with
the activities
now as you note the dropout question
here is going to continue to be a
challenge
but i think that
you know
selection bias in in moocs is just
something that we have to recognize is
going to be there right i mean that's
you know these are students that are
voluntarily entering the moocs to begin
with and
um and i don't have a perfect answer for
that but if we're willing to take their
engagement with the activities and what
this seems to say about how well they're
learning against a specific knowledge
component or outcome it gives us
something to start with yeah i just
don't make sure we are careful when
making causal claims
especially when we try to implement
experiments
in light of these clear selection
problems
it's oh no no i mean we've got to be
aware of it walking in the front door
i really think that
the dropout problem the attrition
problem is is a two component problem
and that that's not recognized
uh
are you a professor no oh okay well a
lot of people here are professors and
you know that when you teach an elective
course
then you know that the kids are trying
out a couple different elective courses
the first week
and they may drop out they may put even
the first assignment but they don't
don't do the second assignment
now in the books of course
this thing is widely in addition to
being elected it's widely publicized and
in addition to that it's uh no
non-credit effective not not useful
degree credit
and so
really if you divide and i've looked at
a lot of
these attrition curves if you
ask yourself how many people who were
passing or who made significant effort
from the second assignment
finish the course
the moocs that that we've run at mit in
in my group but other ones at mit that
i've studied
always about 50 of the people who make a
serious attempt on the second assignment
get certificates
and we've seen up to 75
so from that you just ignore this big
falloff i mean a quarter of the people
never register and never i absolutely
agree with you and one in the course
and it's absolutely true we you know the
the number of people who enroll is like
clicking a like button on facebook
that's what it means the publicity works
right but whether people actually engage
but even then if they have submitted a
first assignment yet there's a lot of us
right and there's a lot of bias still
just yeah
and when we took a similar approach in
that first set of dropout graphs that we
ignored anyone that did nothing more
than enroll i mean that's our starting
population where those that are engaged
in some way
hey so i'm going to change the subject
slightly um one of your questions one of
the challenges had to do with irb
uh and so i'm interested if you could
talk a little more about
what those challenges were particularly
and you could talk all day yeah i mean
not in too much detail but i've sat on
irvs before and and so i'd like to think
a little more deeply about what what
challenges you actually saw and
i mean it is a big
i don't want to call it a barrier to
research because it's so important
but it does pose
logistical challenges especially across
universities things like that and so
it's it's an important discussion that i
don't think we have enough of and it
impedes you know research because people
are either afraid of it or they don't
want to
they don't want to deal with it or
don't know how to deal with it
so i think that one of the single
largest barriers to this is that we do
not have norms for educational research
and educational data specifically
that align well with uh irbs that have
been developed to protect against
what is essentially medical research
right i mean we've got this notion of a
need for
sharing of
learner data
that is comparatively low risk but we
don't have norms for understanding this
and so in many ways each irb is forced
to go it alone as they as they evaluate
what's the relative risk who's getting
access to this so this this is one piece
and we're further burdened by
the regulatory aspect
i think that ferpa in particular is
poorly understood but is uh often
plugged into these issues in ways that
is not productive
one of the ways to address this i think
is is on this norm establishment and i
think the work that happened at acilamar
highered.org
a recent gathering to really drill in on
this question of how do we establish
some principles for treating these
learning data as a public good and being
able to share it in more effective ways
beyond better norms
we need to figure out how irbs across
institutions can work together um they
weren't designed to do this
and uh i mean again i can go off all day
on nightmare stories but let me just
just two pieces
four
so i'm very fortunate in that i have an
irb protocol for oli generally anything
that happens inside of the system in
which my students consent or opt into
the research process
i'm at a fairly significant liberty to
make use of that data and to share it
with other researchers that will
register as an oli researcher
within ccli um we had something like 27
community colleges that were involved
and because there was work happening
outside of the system we needed a
separate protocol
my irb determined that we actually
needed to get irb approval from each of
the individual 27 community colleges who
are not equipped in many cases to to
deal with these types of questions right
i mean it's just it's you know they
often don't have the infrastructure and
so approval ranged from someone in a
provost office sort of sending me an
email saying yes this is fine to a
full-on irb review um
for again what was a
if for something that if i had not been
calling it research but if instead each
of these individual faculty members had
chosen to use these instructional
materials and pre and toast test as part
of their instruction they were
completely at liberty to do so figuring
out how we can work well together in
that space
on the georgia tech side there was
actually an
awful lot of uh
challenge in
the georgia tech's irb who it wasn't
clear had a perfect understanding of
what was being collected for this
specific mooc
and who had issued a blanket protocol
across all five of the moocs that were
happening inside of gates but all with
the assumption that the only researchers
that were going to be involved would be
those at georgia tech and so when we
started introducing additional
researchers
it created some challenges for them that
we ended up
moving around essentially by having our
researchers added to their protocol so
i'm effectively a georgia tech
researcher now
and this created certain interesting
absurdities uh
so joel smith
is one of the
original
contributors or founders to oli at
carnegie mellon um joel is is really
respected really knows his stuff and
joel is so senior to me that i would
ever hesitate to go and ask joel for
anything so needing to go
approach professor dr joel smith and
explain to him that i needed him to
repeat his human subjects training
because of this protocol that was off
somewhere it was an uncomfortable
conversation right
a combination of norms around data
sharing with at least some more
thoughtfulness about how we conduct
cross-institutional research in this
space would go a long way to removing
some of these burdens
some better standards for risk and
and and dealing with that risk i think
would also be helpful
so
question that's
a bit related i wonder if you could
expand on
the collaborative activities that were
done in the mooc and in oli and perhaps
whether or not there's something that's
measuring peer-to-peer work and
student-to-student interaction and what
impact that has on learning and
effectiveness
i cannot speak much to the collaborative
activities
so within the psychology course we
actually on the oli side do not have any
collaborative work
one of the next projects that we've
identified has been to build out more
authentic collaborative activities into
the oli system something carol and i are
hoping to work on
within the mooc
the collaborative activities took two
forms there were some uh discussion
forum questions that aside from
carolyn's review not a lot of digging
has been done on and there was also
um a requirement early in the course for
peer review and feedback and grading of
papers
and
so the students rebelled against this in
a way that i'm continue to be surprised
by i mean they reacted
very strongly to this notion of grading
one another of having uh grades come in
from other students on their work and
essentially refuse to participate um
against the faculty grading as a
component of that exercise
they never got to that point
they were going to be but they never
reached that point i i less than 100
students participated in the first
activity and i believe less than 20 in
the second and they never bothered with
uh releasing the third
and and it seemed like there was a
number of students that were very vocal
in their opposal to this that
engaged the rest of the students in
in this uh uh
strike essentially they weren't going to
do these activities
this was the general mooc population
there's really no stakes involved i mean
exactly yeah what's what's the risk in
this case um my understanding is a
something i didn't reference much but
that was my third
comparison were students that were
taking this uh as at an r1 institution
using the moocs and oli and face-to-face
instruction they obviously did engage in
these activities
but i don't have access to that data
because it's not included under the mooc
irb
sorry i feel like that was a very
unsatisfying answer to your question but
that's that's where we landed
other questions
i mean um since you saw the students
comments about
about refusing to participate in the
further assignments what what did they
cite as their answers did they give any
kind of insight into what they were
unhappy about
uh
so that we're gonna categorize it there
were some students that felt that uh
having other students review their work
did not take into account
some of their own special circumstances
um there were others that just felt that
their peers should not be evaluating
their work and that they did not feel
confident in having their peers
evaluating their work
um
and there were others that i just don't
have a good sense of of
what was going on did that break down by
educational level like you seemed that
the dominant number of people in your
study
in the mooc were already had their phds
were the people that already had their
phds that were refusing to have their
work peer reviewed so it's a great
question
and i i i haven't i haven't taken that
sort of deep dive but it's an
interesting one
other questions
so philosophically i've got one for you
that i every time i look at my
demographic breakdown
i it keeps coming back to me
georgia tech invested a great deal of
time and talent in this effort as did
oli
and the gates foundation put a
non-trivial amount of funding into into
this course and into some of the
subsequent research
and this was an awful lot of resource to
be devoted to what was essentially a
population of folks that had master's
degrees and phds
and
it feels irresponsible to me to not ask
was this a good use of that resource
how do we better target
these kinds of learning experiences
towards the students that need them how
do we how do we really identify and
target appropriate learner populations
at the uh
around 2000 i think i spent about a week
and a half experimenting with day
trading um you know it was the end of
the 90s everybody was doing it so this
distinct recollection of sitting in this
chat forum with other day traders and
some stock started going up and we all
started getting excited about this oh
i'm buying into this i'm buying into
that and finally some experienced day
trader he'd been at it two weeks popped
in and said are you guys selling to each
other
and suddenly all of the traffic on the
stock stopped
dead stopped
so how do we stop selling to each other
particularly in an introduction to
psychology mooc where we know that there
are students that need this how do we
better get this information out to them
um i don't have an answer to that one i
think that's a much bigger question
i was just going to say um i think ed
cottrell's group at microsoft research
india has been doing some great work
work working with the third tier
engineering colleges in india and their
idea was to use moocs as a resource but
to work with the teachers to help them
see how they could use it in their
course and i think if we want you know
to target particular populations we're
going to have to do the same on the
ground work i think we like to sit at
our desks and just do the technology and
put it out there and let somebody use it
but i think we really have to do the
professional development we really have
to do that
on the ground
partnering in order to get it out there
where you know in the populations that
we want to use it
i guess my answer was similar so
i mean yesterday at the at one of the
lightning rounds there were speakers i
think it was the teaching lightning
round there were a
faculty from mission bay community
college which is near well uh
near here
and they used a mooc
and but in in describing what they did
and then when i spoke with them
afterwards they essentially used the
mooc but really what their students were
using were all of the activities that
their faculty had developed to go with
the mooc because the mooc the way it was
designed just was not supporting their
learners and the um
i probably shouldn't say what they said
because i don't know if they want it
publicly said but suffice it to say that
a good deal of the of the learning
activities that were being effective
with their learners were the learning
activities that they contributed not
what was thrown over the wall so i guess
my answer to your question and we did
this all the time and ccoli was engaging
a much greater diversity of faculty
in the development
from the from the beginning
to
if you want these resources to be and
also some of the people from your target
population
uh from the beginning if you want
these resources to be used by some
target population
so
yeah
so the question that comes to mind when
how do we reach our target audience how
do we get high school students and even
undergraduates to do this the question i
think we should be asking is
what what incentive do these people have
to do this i mean there's a lot of
incentive if you're in the workforce
and you have a specific question or or
you're a motivated self-learner
for sure but when you're in the in the
throes of 16 credits
an undergraduate institution
if there's not a big incentive for doing
this i i wouldn't have done it and i've
considered myself a lifelong learner i
wouldn't have done it as a graduate
student i would not have had i didn't do
it there were classes i should have
moocs i should have probably
taken
as a grad student but i did not have the
time or the resources to give to it even
though i knew it was good for me um and
this is a tough question
i was talking i was talking specifically
about using the mooc resources in formal
education where the students are which
incentivizes it yeah and what we're
talking about is there's incentive
there's credit there's there's something
there some sort of incentive structure
credentialing process yeah
but
this question of context i think is
really really important i'm from the
university system of maryland and we
recently engaged in the ithaca study
that repurposed moocs for use in credit
bearing courses and one of the big
findings was the students were fairly
dissatisfied with their moocs because it
didn't fit their context you know if
your student that's attending an hbu
you're there for a reason you you relate
to those faculty or if you've gone to
frostburg to to connect with a
particular faculty member you know when
we when we take these materials and
repurpose them we have to be really
careful about the context i think that's
a big a big piece of it
why are the commercial publishers so
successful in getting people to use
their stuff
you're talking about like the pearson
products and things along those lines
are you talking about textbooks yeah i
mean well for example we
we made my son and i made mastering
physics
and uh it's it's a tutorial system and
it has a library of problems and 400 000
people use it
uh i mean that's ten times as many as
bought the most popular book so it it's
out there
and and so is it the trust is it the
support is it the
imprimatur of
some
publishing company uh is it the young
person who comes by and talks to the
professor and says you know here's my
here's my card here's my cell phone on
it in case you have trouble i mean where
is where where where are we relative to
that how do we get there
i'm not sure i have the answer to that
question but i think this the social
connectedness and the some of the affect
is is definitely a big part of that so
when
we're now we we now have students that
are are watching videos of of faculty
members there's a there's a social
component to that and an interactive
component that feels very different and
feels like i don't necessarily belong
now to that to that discussion um that
and i think as we move into these kinds
of materials that we're going to see see
more and more of those kinds of of
reactions to some of these sorts of
things i don't know i i don't have the
complete answers
so i can i can speak to some uh
adoption studies that we did with
faculty um looking and the and a big
part of the
um
so what are the factors that would make
a faculty member in traditional higher
education willing to adopt
um activities they're designed outside
one of them is it has to definitely be
something that they believe
um
is something that they couldn't have
created better themselves
and part of what pearson has going for
it if they've got a huge sales force
that is out there
um
and and if you look at what pearson's
offering these large textbooks with lots
and lots and lots and lots and lots and
lots and lots and lots of problems that
um most of the things that we're
creating don't have that because just
the the scale of things
um but so where is going so they have to
trust the uh provider they have to trust
that it's effective it has to be
something that they believe they
couldn't have done on their own
and um
and having someone else that they trust
who's used it is huge
and
so yeah that those are the those are the
big things and it has to all
so i'm gonna get a little soapboxy here
there's a challenge here because part of
what we're trying to do at least what we
were always trying to do in oli was not
just
create tools that
supported the way we always the way that
teaching and learning currently happens
oli was in some ways
a or continues to be a trojan horse of
trying to change the teaching and
learning practice to move it more
towards an evidence-based practice so
designing the environments with what we
know about human learning and then using
having people use those environments in
real classrooms collecting the data from
what's working and not working for your
students knowledge state is and and
expecting faculty to look at that data
to make different decisions about what
they do in class that's a real change in
practice so
and there's not enough support in the
existing education system to support
faculty i think to undergo that change
in practice
i mean we look at our students and we
recognize that in students trying to
learn a new skill in a new practice they
need
support scaffolding all of that kind of
stuff and so if we think about the
faculty as the students
and we're just saying okay now you're
supposed to take the way you've taught
things for the last 15 years and
overnight
in figure out how to incorporate this
completely different approach this data
and you know and do it differently
that's that's an absurd thing to be
asking of our faculty
that's you know as i look at um
dashboards like this and think about
faculty's reaction to them it's like
anything else they don't have the
underlying theory to be able to
interpret that so if i don't know that
immediate feedback you know the fact
that i waited two weeks to give
feedback on the quiz was really not a
good thing uh from a theory standpoint
i'm not going to know how to interpret
this so the more that we can build that
kind of scaffolding we've heard it
several times last couple of days more
we can build that kind of scaffolding in
for faculty so that they can begin i
call it hiding the broccoli and the
mashed potatoes the trojan horse sort of
thing so they can begin understanding
how to interpret these data i think that
will help tremendously i agree
and that's time thank you all for
attending
i have great big piles of data if anyone
wants to dive in and start figuring out
some other ways to evaluate learning
with me thanks